[Music]
and Hollywood's open secret expose news
everybody got the hibi submitted by Lord
Nadeau remember we did that it was like
a tornado but it was like a lure Nadeau
I forgot what but it was on a Jay King
news again I don't remember that [ __ ] I
forgot what though but that's one of the
things is that were they referring to me
oh no I think was Jackie a party I think
was a game and then I'll trying to bend
the rules and I said is it okay if I say
Laura Nadeau oh yeah I have a good
memory go gamblers Harvey Weinstein has
been fired from his production company
after allegations surfaced you haven't
been updated with the news how it's like
every yeah it's all over the place
fired from his own production code you
really haven't yes remember we heard
about Harvey Weinstein all over the
place way before this news broke out so
no memory King what my friend told me
was he was working on like a project in
China Vietnam or something like that but
he works out in Asia and this mutual
friend we got has told us that a famous
Asian actress had to go upstairs in his
room and he was offered or she was
offered sex in a role or nothing at all
she came downstairs and refused and told
my friend and she was like I'm gonna
suck my way to the top well she is not a
hard worker is she what sarcasm it's
crazy that this is news though because I
feel like that's the norm that's why
it's like Hollywood open oh I see does
it happen like all the time like there's
rumors of the guy that started guest
Paul Marciano or someone who sleeps with
all his models I just it's just any
industry like you want to make it to the
top you guys sleep around did that
Vanderbeek guy [ __ ] Dawson's Creek
james Van Der Beek is it Jane yeah he
came out saying like he sucked a dude no
no he was just saying when he was
younger he would get like they would
grab his ass and like he would get
cornered and like pressured but like
Kevin Spacey right like he has his way
with a lot of his co-stars and Spacey
really yeah
like molest hella do you know what Kevin
Spacey likes to [ __ ] his co-star dude
that'd be crazy if I ever get to be on
set I want to be sexually harassed once
did you know you're gonna make it you
know you're gonna make it I just like no
I'm just saying like there's some dude
came up no you're good Jimmy let me let
me have dreams like one of my co-star
comes up it's a large male man he goes
listen you got to suck my dick for this
role I'm not gonna do it but thank you
you know did you feel hot yeah it's
flattering you're gonna turn down that
opportunity I would do it whoa whoa
Terry Crews for us and tyka don't even
involve Tycho what the [ __ ] Terry Crews
came out saying that he was sexually her
like they just grabbed it he's so but
like a producer or something like how
they live no they're in the industry and
it's like a exec that comes up it
doesn't matter how but for big you out
this guy has power so you know this guy
can open doors to your entire future so
your work in this industry again that's
why I think it's pretty awesome that now
this is all being revealed and now other
producers now that it's so normal in the
industry now they can maybe think twice
about it because shits on our huge name
celebrities that came out accusing
Weinstein and now it led to him being
fired from his own company but he made
so many good movies that sucks
there's more accountability in the
industry that sucks as they've been
talking about like a lot of the kids
that are getting molested and [ __ ] and
oh that's not cool
only adults should be molested because
they have a no not like getting molested
but adults should be up they have a
choice they have a choice they're gonna
be like no kids are nothing I know
they're impressionable but it also kind
of sucks cuz there's all these people or
like all these kids with dreams are like
one day I'm gonna go to Hollywood and
suck someone's dick and now they can't
even fulfill those feet there's a lot of
people with those feet moving
mates that all they're like I can't wait
til I suck Hugh Hefner's dick so I could
be a star well they can't anymore cuz
he's gone I know so you gotta ruin all
these people's dreams Josh shut ochio
tight cos only your kid
I can't imagine you have there getting a
boner I probably looks like a time-lapse
of a flower growing you missed that JK
news time-lapse of a flower it's like
this straw paper and he put a water on
[Laughter]
you they picked like the worst picture
ever dude he looks like a bulldog like I
don't think you're gonna find a better
better pictures of him but they made
that's the face that's what you're
worried about nothing all I'm saying is
like this is this is how media demonizes
people is like they find the worst
[ __ ] pictures for this guy maybe they
should so anyways this guy is our few
points and this year that's a better
that's a different picture the New York
Times published this like expose type of
thing where they interviewed a lot of
high-profile celebrities and a lot of
them like Rose McGowan and what happened
to her it seems like she kind of got you
know dwindled away because of all of
this drama so back in 1995 whoa that's
her yeah yeah so she looks like now I
don't even know she's frozen guys she
did not look like that before she was
pretty hot she was dating up Marilyn
Manson for a minute oh yeah so she like
didn't charmed or something
yeah okay Rose McGowan was saying that
she ended up settling for $100,000 back
in 1995 after he sexually harassed her
and she had already been open about her
being raped by a Hollywood exec but
because like she signed them in that
show something like she couldn't she can
name him for that so now she broke the
NDA well no because she never said he
raped me it was just like a Hollywood
exec raped me and then he did something
to me like I guess she's not really
emerging the too hot for speculating
that he was the one
raped cuz I laws now if the Indies don't
hold up if it's illegal yeah like I
can't sell someone like heroin and then
well sign and I don't know that I sold
heroin oh yeah that worked because she
got paid like does that no I don't think
I don't think it works that way anymore
or maybe that's why there's all these
like NDA's to protect crime so I don't
NDA's don't hold up if it's illegal uh
like if it's based on something that has
it hasn't always been that way or is it
just recently well I don't know like
when I was in ninety that was like a kid
so I don't really know but now I know
it's that way ah yeah and then Ashley
Judd was saying that like 20 years ago
Harvey asked her to watch him shower and
she oh no that's no harm to watch
someone else that's still sexual
harassment though on one point she went
to the peninsula in Beverly Hills and
that seems to be the hotel where a lot
of these accusations are coming out of
they should call it the rape hotel of
Beverly Hills
so Ashley Judd had a business breakfast
meeting with him and he sent her up to
his room and he appeared in a bathrobe
and then asked if he could give her a
massage or if she could watch him shower
so that was one of the accusations here
he gives her a massage she must suck and
she watches him in the shower
that was he would he was trying to say
like that is hilarious let me do you a
favor
he's pretty generous so this is Zelda
Perkins she was 25 back when she was
harassed by him so it was like
20-something years ago she was an
assistant of his in London apparently he
harassed her and several other women but
she ended up settling out of court so I
can see what these women shuttle because
it's like they don't have nearly as much
money as he do to like combat that so
they're probably like [ __ ] and like what
else can I do like I want to hurt them
but I can't so just [ __ ] pay me out
so what does that teach you be rich so
you stay out of jail
basically yep that's kind of all these
women because a lot of these are saying
I was just an up-and-coming actors I was
trying to make it up there and he took
advantage and he he wanted sexual favors
in order for me to get a role
a lot of these girls are saying I wonder
is there is it the is there another way
around cuz I know a lot of there's a lot
of female producers out there too so I
wonder if female producers do that to
the male counterparts yeah I mean like
probably possible yeah anyone that's in
power like you they could probably get
greedy and they want a power trip yeah
they just bring them up to the hotel is
they hey I need a favor from you like I
need to practice my kegels on your dick
put that on the table not female
producers just people of power it's like
the people that are beneath them that
are like hey I'll do this for you too it
happens to men too like like gay
producers that that they don't care if
you're straight or not they want that
booty yeah like let's say I don't it
happened to me and they're like take me
to there and there's butt-naked they're
like you gotta suck this [ __ ] if you
want before I'm gonna do it but thank
you like I appreciate the gesture did
you find me attractive but but then I
think it's different for us too because
we're not trying to be anything like
we're not trying to be the only actor in
the whole entire world to win a you know
like that's not our dream I think for a
lot of other people it's like this is
all I want yeah like for a lot of actors
that's their only that's their big break
that's what they've been studying 20
[ __ ] years for whatever and it's like
oh [ __ ] there's this ultimatum and this
guy could completely ruin your career
tube so this other producer so her name
is Elizabeth Carlson she's an
oscar-winning producer she said that a
female executive of hers told her 30
years ago that she had found once being
naked in her bedroom in a Mary max
rented property so they were working on
a project and then she just found she
found him he was laying down naked yeah
what to do with women so this is an
Italian actress and model man he looks
like a hotter Katie Holmes oh yeah
her name is Nicole Andra Juliana and she
reportedly had her breasts groped in
2015 by him and then this
is Lauren Sylvane Sylvane and she's an
Xbox host and she said that he
masturbated in front of her in 2007
actually just watched the whole thing
well he cornered her locked her inside
like he rented the whole restaurant
something like that is just like a lot
of these accusations we just have
limited information how is it getting
any work done he said it's like
molesting like that's what I'm saying
it doesn't have like read scripts like I
want to fund this movie I want to fund
that movie but he's just going on maybe
he schedules out his life accordingly
like you know script reading at 5:00
p.m.
rape at 6:00 6:30 you know like it's a
matter of discipline because if you're
gonna you have to orchestrate this [ __ ]
like and then you have to have like a
secretary and all that [ __ ] to help you
like call her up to my room and all this
stuff what these people have whole teams
around them that's right it's the right
team yeah and they also are reporting
that Weinstein enforced a code of
silence in his company so apparently the
employees have contract saying that they
will not criticize it or its leaders of
the company in any way that it could
harm its business reputation or any
employees personal reputation they all
knew that she was doing this are they in
trouble for being like an accomplice to
the crimes of these women that are
coming out another saying a lot of them
were paid off roughly between 80,000 and
150,000 dollars and at the company there
is proof that the company knew about
some of these dirty like dating back two
years ago but then now like that they
fire them you're like we never knew and
any reports that are saying that we did
know are false but then evidence came
out that they somehow did know about
this back in 2015 so a lot of people are
responding to that articles like Susan
Sarandon she ended up saying huge
respect for Ashley Judd and all the
women who broke their silence for the
article and Harvey Weinstein brave and
then Ashley Judd says thank you and then
like Heather Graham same thing Heather
Graham to show our cat
like because they they were also
harassed too or they're just like we've
been hearing this [ __ ] [ __ ] and it's
been too long yeah I should support and
then Lena Dunham she ended up saying
easy to think Weinstein company took
swift action but this has actually been
the slowest action because they always
always knew and then even Mark Ruffalo
he ended up tweeting out like sounds
like Buffalo to be clear what Harvey
Weinstein did was they discussing abuse
of power and horrible I hope we are now
seeing the beginning of the end of these
abuses you know it's funny well it's not
funny but the thing is this is this is
this has been a rumor of him it's been
such a rumor that people that aren't
really even in Hollywood like us know
about this yeah before the news broke
out and then finally it comes out and
it's like oh they caught him finally and
he's been raping for the last 20 plus
years or more well since the 90s right
here he gave a statement to The Times
right after this came out saying
something like I grew up in the sixties
and seventies and back then and it was
different but so it was okay to rape
back in the 60s and quote I appreciate
the way I behaved with colleagues in the
pet in the past has caused a lot of pain
and I sincerely apologize for it no they
don't though I'm trying to do better I
don't have a long way to go and then now
he's working with therapist he's going
to sick Oh his wife is now leaving him
he's been married since 2007 they have
two young kids and the wife said that
she is leaving her husband and that
Weinstein says he supports her decision
she probably knew all along but she was
like you [ __ ] but that's the thing too
it's like even if we heard of this stuff
and we knew about it even when I let's
say we told somebody they just all think
it's here safe like they literally do
not believe that this stuff happens they
think everything is black and white you
know there's just a whole like grayscale
in Hollywood which is the reason why
things like YouTube developed you know
to me we don't have to go through all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] shake hands smile
all this like [ __ ] fake
the same time that all this came out it
also came out youtubers are raping
people that's crazy
yes at the same time that all this
Harvey Weinstein thing came out this
also like this big old scandalous
thinking about we're honest trailers
founder named Andy signor he was also
fired after sexual abuse allegations by
like honest trailers yes like screen
junkies on honest trailers
so this fool apparently he was also
sexually harassing women and so now he's
been fired look at if he looks like a
rapist how does he sexually harass women
yeah because all I saw was trailers in
the voice like I never see the person
behind it so girls would try to work for
his company and he would harasses them
exactly so this woman Emma
so she tweeted this out anyway here's
the whole story about how the screen
junkies guy wanted to jack off in front
of me and then she just detailed like
that popular theme with powerful people
I guess they just like giving [ __ ]
shows they should just be cam boys dude
what the [ __ ] yeah
wrong Ennis you're gonna read her he
looks like he hunts bears for a living
came out saying similar thing I think
anyone in power
there's people are just potential to
abuse it if you're the gatekeeper to
much more things and people trying to
call through those gates but you never
see like the people who are doing like
these heinous acts as handsome chiseled
men you mean like I can take a power
trip thing so yeah but usually they're
like greasy looking and like how we said
before they look like they smell he
probably smells like smegma hey guys I
hope you guys enjoyed the video please
remember to give us a big thumbs up and
a like like like and also when you guys
sign on YouTube make sure just kidding
news though first thing you watch every
single day because we post videos every
day ok for more videos
[Music]